Reefer Madness is now a manslaughter
defense a woman in California getting no
jail time for fatally stabbing her
boyfriend more than a 100 times lawyers
for 32-year-old Brin speecher blaming
marijuana induced psychosis as the
reason why in 2018 she grabbed a sided
bread knife and stabbed her date Chad
more than a hundred times killing him
she also stabbed her dog and tried to
kill herself when cops arrived prior to
all of this Carnage she'd taken two bong
hits speecher was later found guilty of
involuntary manslaughter but
psychiatrist said the stabbing spree was
100% caused by cannabis induced
psychosis the judge agreed and ruled she
experienced a psychotic break from
reality and had no control over her
actions gave her two years probation and
community service and the victim's
friends and family are
outraged he has set a precedent in
California where it appears to be okay
to smoke marijuana and commit a violent
crime she just got away with murder this
100 hours of uh of community service
isn't even one uh hour per stab that she
inflicted on
Chad is this is the hunter Biden defense
judge I don't I I don't have to pay my
taxes I was in a cocaine induced
psychosis you know I I gotta tell you I
mean I'd like to laugh but this is so
painful so many families are like that
that father and the mother who didn't
say anything look the fact that she
voluntarily engaged in smoking marijuana
through a bong makes it clear that she
is culpable okay now let's get something
straight she's convicted of involuntary
manslaughter the only thing that the
bong did it prevented her or the the
consequences of the bong prevented her
from performing the specific intent
which is why she wasn't convicted of a
homicide and intentional murder okay
okay or uh and and that's why it's
manslaughter all right that judge didn't
have to take into consideration that it
was uh psychosis induced uh inhalation
of the marijuana he could have just said
I got one life here gone a young man who
did nothing because she made a decision
to take not just one hit but two hits
from a bong it was her voluntary acts
that caused that man to die I don't care
if they think that she is not
responsible ultimately all I care about
is she couldn't form the intent for
murder but she's still guilty of
involuntary manslaughter she should have
her butt in jail Greg Gutfeld she has a
great lawyer that's for sure because
this is I mean imagine if a drunk driver
plows into a family and kills them and
she was drunk on really hard alcohol
it's like oh it was really powerful
alcohol that shouldn't matter it
shouldn't matter she drank she hit the
family that's it you go to jail jail so
this is a this is strange I think you
know it's
like I keep thinking I wonder if the
what would have happened if the genders
were reversed you know what I mean is it
because it was so brutal and that she's
a female that that was the way they were
able to say it had to have been the drug
because she's a woman and no woman would
stab a hundred times uh you know and and
saying that somehow she was coerced to
take the bong hit I mean this is garbage
she like it's just uh yeah it's it's an
injustice Dana well I agree with all of
that and I keep thinking of somebody
like Daniel Penny who is facing a
involuntary murder charge here in New
York City manslaughter right yeah and
because he and he wasn't on any drugs
because he was trying to protect people
on the subway from a crazy man who was
on drugs that is outrageous yeah
Jessica this High potency marijuana
defense or this drug itself is now going
to turn into something that people are
concerned about and I've been noticing
that amongst my friends who it's legal
here folks who smoke pot that they won't
buy
from a dealer anymore they have to go to
a store right somewhere where you know
that it's not laced with fentanyl or
something else and this I'm sure will be
the new frontier in that that if you
hear that someone and I I don't know
this woman it seems like there should be
greater punishment than what she got for
this um I don't I wouldn't imagine if
she was dating a guy that she went over
there to stab him a 100 times then try
to kill a dog in herself I think
obviously something did chemically react
within her to do it but this is going to
be a new thing that we're going to have
to be concerned about but here's the
thing think about this if you were uh if
you let's say there was a fight and she
stabbed him and on the third stab she
she was like I should just go for I
should go for it because then it went
from murder to psychosis you just do
something completely insane is she like
a Basic Instinct uh make it look insane
both the prosecution and defense agreed
that she was in a psychotic State and
that's why this thing is such a low uh
uh crime which where for which you could
face only four years but what you're
saying is so important Jessica when I
was Da THC was 4% in marijuana today
it's 90% that's a real problem okay
coming up next the homeless crisis goes
deep in America hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else